my friend myself and the think media
team are more excited than buddy the elf
and 10 arctic puffins
because we are giving away a complete
youtube studio now to enter you just go
to win this tech.com of course link in
the description down below i'm talking
about a light kit microphone tripod sd
card and a brand new sony zv
e10 as a side note this is probably the
best camera for youtube right now we
just are absolutely in love with it
whether you want to vlog or shoot
talking head videos or live stream but
you have a chance to win one and all you
have to do is go to win this tech dot
com now when you get there there's going
to be a lot of different ways to boost
your chances of winning and check it out
you actually can come back daily for the
duration of the giveaway period and find
even more ways to enter so if you want
to get more entries than the amount of
christmas lights on clark griswold's
house then i encourage you go to win
this tech.com right now check out all
the details and on behalf of myself and
the entire think media team merry
christmas happy holidays and i can't
wait to see you soon in the next video
[Music]